we regret that we've had to take this
day of action but let's be clear we've
been trying to get the government to
negotiate with us since last July we
have teachers who have nothing left at
the end of the month teachers who tell
me that they're worried about putting
Petrol in the car because they can't
afford it but they need the petrol to go
to work teachers using food banks this
cannot carry on and that leads to
teachers leaving for other jobs which
pay more and which they means they work
let far less hard now they don't want to
do that but if you can't carry on
because you're not being paid enough
then you can't carry on and that has a
massive effect on children's education I
would say to the government that we
don't want to do this again we want this
to be our last day of action
but they have to negotiate and they have
to stop
um
messing about they have to get into a
room and we have to find a resolution to
this dispute it's in their hands